[Music]
so I'm awake right now
this is a wake Pete but there's a whole
nother Pete he's middle of the night
Pete and that guy thinks is some very
random stuff right around 4:00 a.m.
luckily I found a home for all those
thoughts in a segment we call 4:00 a.m.
thoughts
[Applause]
[Music]
shoulda went to Disneyland ever since I
was a kid I always wanted to work with
Ray Romano is it weird that this is
exactly how I pictured him
[Applause]
well what's weird is I've had this dream
before I wake up turn over and see what
I would look like if I were a lesbian
kangaroos hold baby kangaroos in their
pouch but what if there's an even
smaller kangaroo in the baby kangaroos
pouch
how far does it go
[Applause]
I wonder if I could beat up Brad Garrett
[Applause]
he's about half a foot taller than me
but come on that goofy bastard would
never see it coming
why do they call it a bathroom when all
it needs to have is a toilet should I be
taking a bath in my toilet I killed a
spider in my house the other day I
didn't have to kill it but he saw me
masturbating
[Applause]
funny funny cause it's true people
complain that barbie is too skinny but
she probably doesn't eat very much
because she doesn't have a butthole the
show is called Everybody Loves Raymond
but isn't it more important that Raymond
loved Raymond
thank you Ray Romano everybody
[Applause]
[Music]